I was fascinated looking at the Twitter
files I knew that there had been kind of
an embedded special FBI team that was
communicating regularly with with
Twitter shaping some of their content
decisions kind of nudging them towards
censorship of various accounts I just
didn't understand the volume I mean I'm
looking at these emails of major Twitter
Executives they're getting emails almost
every other day from FBI and Department
of Homeland Security officials I mean I
just I can't imagine being at a major
media company or social media company
with that level of pressure from the
National Security State